eu
[Música]
quero falar um pouco sobre a parte que
não tá ali na introdução das belas
palavras do Edu
que é um pouco sobre a minha caminhada
musical a minha alfabetização musical
aconteceu bastante cedo assim Pode dizer
o começo da música bastante bastante
novo
Oi e a partir do momento em que me
coloquei no lugar de professor se
preocupava um pouco porque eu não sabia
exatamente como essa troca aconteceria E
desde muito pequena Sempre achei
professoro mas uma profissão Fantástico
profissão mais legal de todos assim mais
importante e sigo acreditando muito
nisso até por por isso me encontro hoje
nessa posição Eu só não sabia ainda como
isso ia acontecer e eu não sabia que era
que era possível eu sentia que precisava
nascer com um jeito para aquilo com
algum tipo de Dom e eu não me sentia
nesse lugar aí
E com o tempo repreendendo que que não
era assim que funcionava E era algo que
a gente poderia aprender
e eu aprendi e sigo aprendendo todos os
dias que
ensinar também a aprender e é um
aprendizado constante
Oi e eu comecei a estudar desde os
educadores musicais até os tipos de
aprendizagem né quem trabalha
aprendizagem visual quem aprende vendo
que aprendi ouvindo os operadores
cinestesicas que aprendem fazendo que
aprender com a mão da massa né Eu sou um
desses é só duas sinestésica talvez até
pela pela questão musical né porque na
música A gente precisa disso depende da
prática vindo antes da teoria
esse lugar de autonomia também é muito
importante né a gente não não teorizar
todas as coisas e colocar tudo no papel
e seguir uma regra primeiro a gente
precisa fazer se como Renê bem lembrou
muitas muitas das coisas são urgentes a
gente tem as urgência de fazer a gente
precisa agora então a gente precisa
fazer fazer fazer na música também
funciona assim a gente precisa fazer
depois a gente para e Analisa e vê o que
Oi gente gostou não se tiver fazer de
novo se a gente pode de repente pensar
num jeito novo de fazer e essa
exploração e autonomia vem muito da
questão de ser instrumento a minha maior
parte da minha caminhada vem do canto
coral né que é um encanto em conjunto
sem acompanhamento na sua maior parte
então eu também sou instrumentista Mas
eu sou mais cantor e músico corporal de
qualquer coisa então ser um instrumento
sempre foi uma coisa presente para mim
né E também é uma
questão que leva algumas
responsabilidades
até do no sentido de ser um instrumento
orgânico é porque se se o violonista tá
um pouquinho gripada ali isso não
interfere no violão dele especificamente
mas se eu fico doente EA minha voz vai
para o espaço né então
só tem essas questões
aí
esse sempre foi a paixão a música
corporal a e eu acabei iniciando os meus
estudos em música E com o tempo essa
música preparar o chegou para mim
bom e ser meu próprio instrumento eu fiz
toda a diferença no trato com os meus
alunos para eu trazer esse lugar de
exploração e autonomia que eu sentia
falta também quando quando eu estava no
lugar de aluno Foi algo que eu precisei
aprender a prestar atenção também desde
o meu lugar de a lua entra no lugar de
professora
bom então uma coisa que
comidas Eduardo Marinho né a gente a
gente nasce aqui e é jogado nesse mundão
aí é obrigado a participar Isso é fato a
gente não tem escolha nesse sentido mas
o que eu quero escolher e eu não abro
mão de escolher como eu vou participar
EA música é a ferramenta que eu escolhi
para isso e é parte do trabalho que eu
faço com o Botucatu que é um Núcleo de
Estudos e vivência em música corporal
e eu tenho um apoio gigantesco da minha
grande mestre é linka e também um
contato maravilhoso com um grupo gigante
internacionalmente conhecido e e muito
respeitado tanto aqui no Brasil quanto
lá fora que o grupo barbatuques né é que
era encabeçado aí pelo pelos grandes tem
Mendes Fernando barba The Sims o início
desse ano nos deixou
sua benção Grande Mestre
Oi e esse trabalho que a gente
desenvolve tanto de performance quanto
de pesquisa acabou sendo o meu meu ex
principal me sala de aula para devolver
a autonomia e exploração para os meus
alunos que como é que a gente aprende a
falar português por exemplo desde que
está na barriga da nossa mãe todo mundo
a nossa volta tá falando português o
tempo inteiro e a gente tá ali escutando
então é criado todo um ambiente para que
a gente possa desenvolver essas
habilidades
e eu acredito que também pode funcionar
assim para a música então eu tento criar
esse mesmo ambiente eu quero criar um
ambiente onde o fazer musical seja
inevitável
eu sou meu próprio instrumento se tu
pudesse até o próprio instrumento a
gente só precisa estar aqui estar com o
corpo disponível e querer fazer
bom então esse é o lugar de
onde é inevitável que a música acontece
Oi E para isso eu quero convidar vocês e
quero proporcionar deixar um presentinho
né diretamente do Botucatu que
é um instrumento um instrumento bastante
específico que eu vou levar para vocês e
vocês vão
estar devidamente apropriadas como a
gente dá uma mudança
então no Botucatu a gente desenvolveu
[Música]
sistematizando também né com trabalho do
barbatuques e por uma influência porque
nada disso da música corporal e
inventado né a gente não tem registros
de sociedades na história que não tem um
presença de música tá então a música
corporal sempre esteve aqui nada disso é
inventado tudo descoberto por isso a
importância da Autonomia exploração bom
então eu vou convidar vocês para fazer
junto comigo quando a gente coloca aqui
no peito esse toque do peito a gente
chama de Tuntum
aqui é o tempo certo e quando a gente
faz o estalo o estava a gente chama de
17 então aqui é o tum e aqui é o
e pra gente fazer uma frase musical a
gente vai fazer assim a gente vai tocar
aqui um
os outros tal e volta perfeito
então a francesinha fica com
um e é importante falar atrás junto
Porque a partir do momento que a gente
decora
essa frase musical a gente não esquece
mais o grupo né então a gente vai fazer
11 e para formar um ciclo a gente vai
ligar o primeiro com o último para ficar
assim tum tum
tum tum tum tum tum tá
suando familiar para vocês tá vindo de
algum lugar isso deixa eu mostrar não
deixe o samba morrer
Não deixe o samba
acabar o morro foi feito de samba mar de
samba pra gente e
não deixe o samba morrer
Não deixe o samba
acabar o morro foi feito de samba mar de
samba pra gente sambar
e aqui está um pandeiro de samba de
presente para vocês e eu espero que
vocês vão com o tempo aí
acariciando ele se apropriando mas eu
quero que vocês estejam prontos para
serem agente da mudança onde é que vocês
forem Esse foi o meio que eu encontrei
de fazer e a ferramenta que eu escolhi
para participar certo pra encerrar Quero
mostrar para vocês um pouquinho do
trabalho do Botucatu também como
performance Então queria mostrar uma
música que é uma composição de um grande
amigo meu
Gustavo athlete chamada Groove nas
alturas
eu vou mostrar um pouquinho aqui para
vocês vende salvar o Gustavo
ela começa assim
E aí
o jogo e
o
qual para para pa pa
para pa
pa pa
papapa
é o que é o batuque do Pedro do coração
que eu faço sem querer que eu faço sei
por que que eu faço sem saber se é você
musical ser sentimental ser racional
inteiro por poste o batuque é bom
Sagrada problema de cachorro corpo disse
que o meu próprio esqueleto é mágico
demais objeto essa português não foi
acabar com
a gente brincou ela o filme papel a
diversão nesse mundo tão louco YouTube é
conseguir ao seu
negócio dentro do Sol II
E aí
e a música corporal como um instrumento
de exploração e autonomia Muito obrigado
a